it's always a good idea to make friends
with your neighbors especially when your
work might lead them to believe you're
the jigsaw killer as experienced s
franchise director Kevin grur revealed
in an interview with mme one of the
torture scenes in sawx was apparently so
brutal that it got first assistant
editor Steve forer in trouble with his
neighbors and local law enforcement
appropriately the scening question
involves the poster trap for s x aka the
eyeball trap the continuity Laden saw X
St between the first two films depicts a
John Kramer who has recently learned
that the progression of his brain cancer
has left him with only months left to
live in the film Kramer catches one of
the hospital's custodial staff
attempting to rub an unconscious and
seemingly mortally ill patient in a
moment of impotent rage he imagines
torturing the konian as jigsaw by
strapping the man into a machine that
will force him to individually break all
five fingers in one hand or be punished
by having his eyes sucked out of his
head by an industrial vacuum it's
without question one of the most
unforgettable moments of sawx with that
single scene delivering a genuinely
impactful character beat some subtle
foreshadowing and a meticulously
agonizing violence that fans expect and
Delight in due special recognition for
the scene's effectiveness is actor Isam
paman Lee who gave a grounded and mostly
isolated performance as a thie in
custodian his acting was so convincing
in fact that when Steve former was
editing this exact scene his neighbors
thought he was torturing someone in his
apartment while editing audio for the
eyeball trap scene neighbors of Steve
forner presumably unaware of what he did
for a living became concerned that the
mild mannered artist was torturing
someone in his home as a home video
camera reportedly captured LAPD officers
responded to the disturbance call and
knocked on his door at which point a
startled forer answered likely hoping
that his excuse of working on a movie
wasn't one that real serial killers
employ according to forer the cops told
him that the neighbors had rang them up
accusing him of violently torturing a
real person after explaining that he was
simply cutting together a scene for a
horror film for Warner even invited the
officers in to watch the sequence for
themselves the realization was enough to
send the cops into a fit of laughter
before they politely declin the
invitation and left forer to his bloody
workload though forer was likely at
least a bit shaken the ordal seems to
greatly amuse gr tur who served as the
lead editor on the first saw film back
in 2004 fora marveled to nme I can only
imagine the look on his face when he
realized what was happening in a morbid
sort of way it's almost impressive that
SX was able to elicit such a WR reaction
through its audio alone though jigsaw
Antics have historically proven to
impact audiences in such a way more than
you might expect the saw franchise is
well known for its exceptionally
gratuitous score most of which is
delivered through excruciatingly drawn
out sequences of torture by the time the
third installment arrived in 2006 there
was enough of a risk of genuine injury
that the guardian reported that a
British ambulance trust issued an
official advisory upon its release East
anglian ambulance trust spokesperson
Matthew W stated people need need to be
aware this film was not for the
squeamish or faint-hearted as well as
collapses we have had reports of people
running screaming from the cinemas so
three features some of the franchise's
most gruesome traps folded tightly into
Jeff denon's game in which he must save
the lives of those responsible for the
death of his son and as well as the
miscarriage of justice that followed
notably many of the traps were designed
to be unwinable by Amanda young such as
the diying angel trap that executes
detective Allison Kerry equally
disgusting are the rack the freezer room
and the opening classroom trap all of
which could easily send an unsuspecting
viewer running for the toilet where
continued every now and then a film
comes along that some people find hard
to stomach so or three appears to have
sent film goers over the edge assuming
that those individuals reporting
distress were not seriously harmed it's
hard to imagine Lionsgate could have
paid for better publicity and while SX
arguably has more going for it than any
previous installment in terms of
narrative heft it's comforting to know
it didn't have to sacrifice is headline
making violence in the
process